it's time for drew's news where we rub
the good news sticks together until we
get that good news fire and with me at
the desk my co-pilot he's always hot hot
hot rossi ross matthew hi
i love everybody
thank you
um all right well before we get started
um we're continuing our cash bonanza in
pop quiz
we love this
we love this um at the end of the show
someone's gonna get in this money booth
that we have and go nuts yeah that's
right for every trivia question you get
right you get 10 seconds in the booth if
you get all three right you get 30
seconds you know how much money is in
there ten thousand dollars
[Applause]
all right
let's uh hit the headlines yeah good
stories today lots of good stories but
first can i just do a little brag about
my friends um okay i went on amazon and
guess what the number one cookbook is
right now
rebel homemaker by drew barrymore
guys
that's you number one
drew excited it is so exciting
and i have to say like it has 300 of my
personal photographs um it's all my
writing and essays and it was a real
labor of love so it's a relief that it's
doing well you know what phew phew
literally
um okay this is a fun story um the
kardashian sisters kim and courtney took
a trip to knott's berry farm this
weekend and this is an exclusive from
people.com they report snl's pete
davidson joined them and was spotted on
a roller coaster holding camps with kim
k and they say reportedly they're just
friends oh they're just friends um
look at this picture of them holding
hands on the roller coaster because this
is really what caught my eye their hands
are you know i'm not good with the left
yeah you're not good at that it's the
way ready one two three
i noticed
it's the intertwining it's the finger i
know listen because it's not this
it's this
and there's a difference because if you
and i are on a roller coaster i would
hold your hand if you were scared but i
don't know that we would intertwine if
you know what i mean and i think
that pete davidson he knows how to
intertwine okay well think about ariana
grande there was rumors maybe dena
and people don't get it with him i don't
get how people don't get it you know
he's cute he's funny he's a bad boy it's
like looking in a mirror you know
i have a question though if kim and pete
are
dabbling no i i happen to know somebody
who knows them and says it is not on and
he was at a knicks game with another
girl
uh recently
juice tea
i love you drew's always got the inside
scoop i love that
all right well i want to know what you
think about this story because you know
people hang out as friends some people
hang out with exes and page six reports
jennifer lopez and ben affleck took
their respective kids out
trick-or-treating along with his ex jen
garner it was ben and jen
and jen
or jen ben jen it could be a it's a gen
sandwich with a ben in the middle and
apparently the kids are all friendly
they all get along which is great it's
one big happy modern family but you know
you have a situation would you do this i
did it what yes i went trick-or-treating
on sunday with will and um and his
beautiful um
wife ali my daughter's wonderful
stepmother
and
um i think honestly i this is so ideal
it is the dream and i i love seeing this
i really do i'm it's very positive i
think it's very elevated i think it
takes a lot of hard work to get where
you are
and to get where you know ben and the
gens are and i think it's because
there's kids there when there's kid
you've got to do the work right because
you're never never not together if you
have children so i don't you know all
the modern family and the
exes aside you're just parents yeah
that's what makes sense to me kids are
the most important
i i say this just trying to put one foot
in front of the other with a lot of love
and good intentions high road baby less
traffic
i love that
high road less traffic and if there's
one thing i hate it's traffic i'd rather
be in hell than traffic but you do have
that nice minivan right i do have a
minivan yeah
um there's like
halloween costumes all over the floor
bags of chips it's it's nuts yeah
it's nuts does anyone else like have
kids at a messy car
thank you to the one woman
may i ask your name and how it gets here
because i am not so sure how the road to
this situation happens
um amy amy george hi i'm true hi
um
kids are just beasts i mean really
and it's we're busy right so you're
eating on the run and
everybody leaves their stuff in your car
and it's just it's rough well amy thank
you for making me feel less alone
because it is so far past the point of
disruptive ball like there is ramen
hanging out of the side card that is so
gross i know that's so gross
we're not we're not carpooling to work
all right i just decided right now amy
you know thank you you know amy knows
thank you so much
okay
well drew you know we've got the latest
workout challenge and it comes from the
one and only oscar-winning actress
lupita nyong'o i love her i love her
obsessed look at her wow look at her i
know and so she's on if you look at
she's on an exercise ball quite the uh
little workout there
i'm obsessed with this video because she
is kneeling on one of those round yoga
balls and she does it for a full minute
apparently
you look like that if you can do that
okay
which we don't okay no shave but i would
you want to try this oh my god anything
that peter nawanga does yeah i always
say i have strong core values but not a
strong core
i'm i'm with you we have an exercise
ball right here
wait wait come here
we're gonna we are gonna cheat just a
little bit we have like training wheels
we wanna abs like lupita so she kneels
on it and somehow i don't know how we're
gonna do this this is
oh god wait is she like fully on the
ball
[Applause]
do you know how hard this is
you got yes
i'm going down
okay now what do i do she was gyrating a
lot she was like she
she did this and then she did it was
doing a little dance you guys
are you okay are you okay i'm fine
[Music]
you